Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Temperature is a measure of energy.
How fast the molecules in something like an
ice cube are moving.
But how does the brain read that information?
For scientists, it’s been a bit of mystery.
But new research published in the journal
Nature sheds a little light.
The research looked at fruit fly brains to
see how it responded to temperature.
They identified three types of neurons that
reacted.
Two sets were what the researchers called
“narrowly tuned”, they could detect either
hot OR cold.
One set of neurons let us know very quickly
whether something was becoming hot or cold.
Another set was a little slower, but traded
accuracy for speed.
These neurons could report temperature better.
But in a surprise to the researchers there
was a third set of neurons that was fast and
“broadly tuned”, it responded quickly
and could sense both hot and cold, possibly
as a ‘mayday’ kind of signal.
So that’s an idea of what might be going
on in the brain.
But how does the feeling get there?
Well in humans, we take in a lot of our information
through our somatosensory system.
This is made up of things like nerve endings,
touch receptors and receptors for temperature
called Thermoreceptors which lie just under
our skin.
It’s thought that the mammalian nervous
system has separate thermoreceptors in our
skin for either warmth or cold.
There are far more cold receptors beneath
the skin than warm ones, and are more concentrated
in areas like the nose and ears and the signals
from cold receptors actually travel to the
brain up to ten times faster than signals
from warm receptors which is why those spots
get so chilly so quickly.
But some cold receptors respond when we touch
something really hot, like over 113 degrees.
Which is why sometimes the hot water in your
show feels icy cold.
This phenomenon, is called paradoxical cold.
And scientists aren’t sure why, exactly.
Weird, right?
Anyways, these thermoreceptors on our skin
send this information to our nerve cells in
our spine, and this is where things get interesting.
The membranes surrounding these nerve cells
have proteins that open and close in response
to different temperatures.
This allows charged particles to move from
cell to cell, sending information up into
our brains.
Our body has dozens of these proteins, called
Ion channels, allowing us to experience a
wide range of temperatures.
These channels can sometimes respond to things
other than temperature, like food, pain or
acidity.
One of the channels called TRPV1, reacts to
hot temperatures—about 100 degrees Fahrenheit.
But it also responds to capsaicin, the thing
that makes chili peppers so spicy, which is
why our body tastes chili but senses heat.
Another of these channels, TRPM8, is sensitive
to cold.
And guess what this channel also responds
to?
Yeah you guessed it menthol, which is the
thing that makes mint seem cool.
Speaking of hot and cold, have you ever wondered
what your life would look like in thermal?
our very good friends over at buzzfeedblue
recently looked at some everyday situations
as scene through a thermal camera!
It was really weird and really beautiful.
Check it out!
It's the first link in the description if
you are on your mobile phone.
Alright guys, do you like it hot or cold?
Let us know in the comments below.
and while you’re at it hit those like and
subscribe buttons and keep coming back here!
we’ve got new episodes every day of the
week.